protesters wore bandages in a sign of
solidarity with students at Jamia Millia
Islamia University in New Delhi they
accused police in the capital of beating
them up while demonstrating against the
new citizenship law two weeks ago in
unison they chanted slogans against the
law and re-enacted a moment of
resistance when a group of female
students formed a circle around their
male friend trying to protect him from
the police Chonga anak turista who were
a part of the group say their university
was targeted because most students are
Muslim the attack was not on the
protesters I would say but the the whole
attack was on the Muslim identity and
all the Muslim community Delhi police
declined to comment on the allegations
[Music]
[Music]
Sabiha boss joined yet another protest
in the capital to raise her concerns
about the safety of her family in the
neighboring state of Uttar Pradesh where
over a thousand protesters have been
arrested many people have just been
picked up by the police in their homes
and their voice is not reaching Delhi
this is a complete media shutdown and
people are terrified at least 26 people
have been killed in almost three weeks
of nationwide protests condemning the
citizenship law police say only one of
the deaths was due to officers opening
fire theoretically the Home Ministry
should be answerable the question is of
holding them to account there is a
feeling in the administration that they
can get away with anything
therefore the Home Ministry often
indicates to local police authorities
that whatever they do it would be fully
supported by the administration who
justice say one
the government makes it mandatory for
everyone to be registered in a national
registry their citizenship law will
protect Hindus but exclude Muslims the
Indian government denies the law is
discriminatory as hundreds in New Delhi
chanted slogans condemning the
legislation they were confronted by
supporters of the law it's the kind of
division many in India are worried about
aunt Aurora al-jazeera New Delhi